Kaguya hospice team you know Cherokee
Mobley's say macho cleavage villa Ko Ko
coyote Benicia Astana betwe no Kikuyu
Wayne Cato repose at Kanye's Savoy no
Kane no mo ghost about substr Anya
pikapika Bonavena
voce esta Rose Madonna tortoise wrench
Allah Allah
muy secrétaire Sarah oh no Jane Caruso
secret
machete or nauseous mission a mission a
Tamiya CB resonance
diaw
[Music]
cogs in Shimoda tweetums Rashad's stress
rats
miss palsy ownership in super hf7
geobella Bonnie Proteus eskimo knee
boots free sushi
[Music]
hey youtubers happy 2017 so new Wonder
Woman foot is just hyping up the god
killer sword some of the action of the
film so I'm gonna explain like what that
is because it's a really cool weapon
there is a new round of the flash ring
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber leave a comment on
this video be sure to click that Bell to
enable alerts so you don't miss anything
most of this is just hyping up like the
crazy action of the film most
International trailers whichever country
they're dropping them in or whichever
language they're in tend to hype the
action just because you don't need to
speak a foreign language to understand
Wonder Woman stealing the god killer
sword or punching someone in the face or
just spinning all over the screen
kicking so much ass so thankfully we get
some new footage but this is cut out of
order like you see Wonder Woman watching
Steve Trevor's plane crash at the
beginning but then it jumps all the way
to the German soldiers rushing the
Amazons on the beach which seems like it
happens much later in the film the only
reason for the Germans the Kaiser this
is World War one so we're talking about
the Kaiser here - what famous Kyra is
because of some resource that the
Amazons might have they do have a mother
box in their possession but they haven't
really explained how much of the dark
side wars are going to explain during
the Wonder Woman movie within the
context of the DC EU we know that there
are three mother boxes on the earth we
saw one of the Justice League trailer
and we saw Lex Luthor learning about
them at the end of Batman vs Superman
that thing that lex luthor's getting all
that information from is supposed to be
Steppenwolf or at least like the
Kryptonian computers edges sketch
version of Steppenwolf so this is really
like the Kryptonian ship speaking to him
this isn't actually Steppenwolf speaking
to him he's learning based on the
Kryptonian database about Darkseid and
all these other galactic threats so that
kind of informs his character a little
bit but they cut that out of the main
movie that everybody saw in theaters is
in the Ultimate Edition though so we'll
circle back around to that because that
explains why Lex Luthor was being so
crazy in the Batman V Superman movie but
aside from like the brief explainer that
Zack Snyder gave us a long time ago
about the Earth's history with Darkseid
we don't really know how that's going to
carry forward into the other spin-off
films presumably we will see another
mother box show up during the Aquaman
movie because there are a couple other
ancient races of people including the
Amazons and the Atlanteans that would
have been around for the first big fight
with Darkseid so it's not like the
German troops want to take famous gira
just because they need a new vacation
spot there's got to be some sort of
resource that's going to help them
conquer the world in legend of a mother
box would just be one of those things
but that's you know Danny Huston is like
the big villain of the film so whatever
the reason for them attacking it would
flow from him but it seems like it's
happening after all these other weapon
tests that happen later in the trailer
like we slowly see the Germans
experimenting with poison gas that's
really kind of like mustard gas that was
like the real big chemical weapon of
World War one it would like completely
scar people's faces it was really bad
even for people wearing gas masks so
that's just what they're implying here
and I know a lot of people are wondering
who this person is here because people
like his Ares in the film he's like
Wonder Woman's biggest villain I don't
know that Danny Huston is playing Ares
in disguise he could totally be Ares but
it seems like he's just a really evil
German officer right now this looks like
it's doctor poisoned just because doctor
poison is a big Wonder Woman villain her
family has a long history of fighting
against the Amazons in the comics so she
has a big grudge against them so you
kind of get the idea just you know from
these trailers that the Amazons don't
want to have anything to do with the
outside world like Hippolyta standing
next to Wonder Woman here
doesn't want to have anything to do with
Steve Trevor Wonder Woman herself and
I'll explain the god-killer sort in a
second because there's like a really
badass quote from Athena on it
Wonder Woman herself has to defy orders
because it actually kind of flows from
the quote on the sword here you can't
really read it in these trailers but
it's actually a quote they borrow from
Joseph Campbell and it's from mysteries
of the feminine divine and it reads life
is killing life all the time and so the
goddess kills herself in the sacrifice
of her own animal so the goddess it's
referring to is Athena
Athena's animal form is like a deer or a
stag so it's sort of a lament that as
you kill other people you're also
killing yourself a little bit so it's
like the tragedy of war which flows a
lot from what's happening with world war
1 so they're trying to get really meta
with the war theme of the film Wonder
Woman is a warrior she's like one of the
biggest warriors in the Justice League
even though everybody's a badass in the
Justice League Wonder Woman herself
walks around carrying a shield and a
sword so the sword itself does have
special properties it's called the god
killer sword because it's Athena sword
but also as you use it to take life
you're killing the goddess Athena so you
kind of have to imagine that Wonder
Woman is really sad at the thought of
having to kill people so they believe
all life is sacred which is why she
believes Steve Trevor and wants to help
him end world war 1 but because of where
we meet her in Batman V Superman we know
that that probably doesn't end well just
because even though she's been living in
the real world
she's retreated from public life since
the end of this Wonder Woman movie
wherever this leaves off back in 1918 so
like the way Zack Snyder explained it is
that when we meet Wonder Woman in Batman
V Superman she's kind of been leading a
very private life for the past hundred
years so it just implies something
really terrible happens at the end of
this movie probably to Steve Trevor just
because he's the love interest in her
whole mission is to try and bring peace
to the world something I'd like to show
now some scholars insist that it never
happened but I believe it's the action
perfectly in keeping the king who was
also a psychopathic killer for me it's
the combination of 14 years curating and
I can't believe it but I finally got it
here it's the sword of Alexander
it's the blade that cut the Gordian knot
it's a triumph yes joy
it's a fake the real one was sold in 98
on the black market
now it hangs over the bed of the sole
Thunderhead jar
it was actually this big thing last year
where like the character Wonder Woman
became this big figure at the United
Nations
Wonder Woman herself as a character is a
peacemaker even though she'll totally
kick people's asses but Linda Carter in
gal gadot actually did this big United
Nations thing so that had a lot to do
with the 75th anniversary of the Wonder
Woman character so I'll be really
interested to see you know with the
political climate what it is how they
try to use the Wonder Woman character to
market the film internationally like if
everyone's saying that 2016 was the year
of zero chill then maybe Wonder Woman
will try to change that in 2017 but I
know a lot of you asking about like
post-credits like we have Justice League
coming in November does that mean that
there's going to be a Justice League
post-credit in present day at the end of
the Wonder Woman movie so they don't
really show you in this trailer but in
the previous trailers we actually see
her walking by the Louvre in present day
in France so the Diana Prince persona
that she walks around using during
present day is an antiquities dealer so
it sounds like either at the beginning
of the film or at the end of the film
there's a remembrance of things that
happen and then they flash back but
either way the film does take place
during present day and then back during
the past most of the film is back during
the past year during this World War 1
period so what's going to happen later
tonight is they just confirm the Doctor
Strange is going to be an important part
of Thor Ragnarok
now we knew he was going to be somewhere
in there but I'll do a video explaining
what's going on with that it's going to
be a lot of fun Benedict Cumberbatch
Chris Hemsworth in Mark Ruffalo the Hulk
Doctor Strange and Thor teaming up it's
going to be awesome so I will say
congratulations to this week's flash
ring giveaway winner louise Diaz please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details there is a new round that
started in this video so I'll just
announce the winner the next time I post
a DC video which will probably be the
flash that should be Wednesday morning
what you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for my 2017 high trailer
for like all the big stuff that's coming
and you can click here so know why
everyone's freaking out about the Batman
movie thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight